this episode was made possible by Dollar
Shave Club get their daily essentials
kit for just 5 bucks by following the
link below the animal kingdom is full of
examples of creatures adapting to their
ever-changing environment since the
beginning of history no single life-form
has caused such rapid and far-reaching
change as humans have our influence and
the consequences of our civilization
have affected every biome on earth
whether directly or through manmade
climate change the ways animals have
adapted to live in our wake are varied
and fascinating so in this episode we're
going to look at a few examples let's
start with the red deer that inhabit the
Czech Republic and Germany the border
between the two countries is completely
passable and unobstructed by natural
barriers but these deer simply won't
cross over why to answer that let's go
back in time during the Cold War when
the Communists came into power in
Czechoslovakia three electrified fences
were installed along the border between
their country and West Germany these
barriers were impossible to cross and
heavily patrolled by armed guards nearly
500 people were killed trying to get
through the red deer in the area learned
the fence network was impassable and
eventually stopped going near it after
the Cold War ended nearly 30 years ago
the electrified fences came down but it
seems the deer never got the memo to
this day the two red deer populations in
Germany and the Czech Republic refused
to pass through the location where the
fences used to stand interestingly it's
not just the same deer remembering the
barrier since the average lifespan of
Red Deer is only 15 years these younger
generations learned from the older ones
that this border is the edge of their
world scientists use GPS collars to
track the movements of 300 deer in the
two populations and confirmed that while
the area the fences stood is nothing but
woodlands and open fields now neither
group ever passes through to the other
side the border is still a real barrier
to these animals meanwhile in Borneo the
local orangutan population has found a
small silver lining to the widespread
destruction of their home cost by
logging these critically endangered Apes
have been observed doing something
unusual instead of traveling through the
forest high up in the tree canopy
they've started walking on the ground
along paths created by loggers one
scientist set up dozens of cameras in
three separate sections of forest each
section representing a different level
of impact from logging in each of the
three areas the cameras recorded photo
of orangutans walking along the timber
paths this is curious because it was
previously thought that orangutans
preferred to stay in the tree canopy to
avoid danger whenever possible experts
suspect that the main reason we see
orangutans opting to walk on the ground
is the significant energy it allows them
to save as opposed to swinging through
the treetops while these Apes may prefer
to save a bit of energy in their daily
lives there is no question that
continued logging is putting this
amazing species at great risk of
extinction in Africa another species of
ape has adapted in an even more striking
way in the rainforests of Guinea many
locals set snares to catch animals to
eat these snares have historically been
the demise of many unfortunate
chimpanzees but now throughout these
rainforests chimpanzees have learned not
only to identify these traps but also to
disarm them even more fascinating is the
fact that these chimps go out of their
way to locate and disarm traps whether
they're doing it to save themselves
trouble or they have some vendetta
against the region's hunters as anyone's
guess the discovery of these chimpanzee
bomb squads was made by accident across
Africa there had been many reports of
chimps being severely injured or killed
by hunting snares until in one region
those reports simply stopped
primatologist observed chimpanzees in
that region of Guinea and saw something
remarkable a group of chimps actively
dismantling a snare the elder of the
group broke the snare then the younger
chimps came forward to inspect it
scientists witnessed similar events in
the region on multiple occasions but so
far the knowledge does not seem to have
spread very far chimpanzees are thought
to learn mostly by trial and error but
in the case of lethal snares and error
likely means death experts believe that
in this case chimpanzees have begun to
learn by observing the effects of the
traps on other animals and slowly
learned which parts of the snare are
dangerous and which can be safely
touched to disarm them it's likely that
over time this new knowledge will spread
to chimpanzee populations across the
continent one final example of the
adaptability and resilience of animals
comes from none other than man's best
friend
specifically the giant population of
stray dogs in Moscow with one stray per
300 humans in Moscow the scientific
community has been able to gather a
wealth of data on these resourceful
animals including dividing the
population into four distinct
personality groups guard dogs wild dogs
scavengers and beggars one scientist has
studied the 35,000 strays for the past
30 years over the decades he's watched
them become
wolf-like losing the spotted coats
wagging tails and trusting friendliness
that domestic dogs exhibit the guard dog
portion of the population hangs around
security personnel across the city
accepting food from them and acting as
semi team deterrence to trespassers the
scavengers wander around the city eating
trash and unattended food the wild dogs
are the most wolf like hunting small
game in the night but the most
interesting group is the beggars these
dogs have adapted some highly
specialized skills they're able to
reliably identify which humans will be
friendly and give them food and they use
their powerful sense of smell and their
recollection of train conductors words
to successfully navigate the city's
metro system incorporating many stops
into their daily routine in stark
contrast to other groups of strays the
beggar dogs have a hierarchy that favors
intelligence over strength in beggar
packs it's not the strongest dog that's
the Alpha but the smartest the first
mention of Moscow stray dog problem
dates back to the mid-1800s since that
time the majority of dogs that become
strays have been rejected house pets
experts estimate that only 3% of these
new strays survive long enough to breed
so the current population of Muscovites
strays really are the strongest smartest
and best adapted around strongest
smartest and best adapted sounds like
you doesn't it or at least how you see
yourself
why not reward yourself for being the
pinnacle of humanity and get the daily
essentials kit from Dollar Shave Club we
all have our morning routines shower
brush teeth make sure it doesn't look
like you just rolled out of bed just
generally looking and feeling
presentable that's why I appreciate the
daily essential starter kit from Dollar
Shave Club honestly I had no idea they
offered more than just razors but they
actually have all sorts of grooming
products toothpaste body wash hair
styling products everything you need to
look feel and smell your best
I tried their calming body cleanser and
it's great I'm not big on going out and
finding all my separate grooming
supplies so I find it super convenient
the Dollar Shave Club sends you
everything you need in one convenient
package especially because of how
reasonably priced it is for the quality
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving
away their daily essentials starter set
to new members for only 5 bucks this
starter set features three trial size
versions of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh and clean along
with their executive razor after the
first box replacement cartridges are
sent for just a few bucks a month this
$5 offer is available at Dollar Shave
Club calm and thought so make sure to
visit Dollar
club by following the link below if this
is your first time visiting remember to
subscribe and click the bell to be
notified of future videos and if you're
not sure what to watch next
check out these playlists as always
thanks for watching and supporting
second thought and we'll see you next
week